yeah hugh jackman I see you going for
the Oscar in this movie seriously though
you should probably get nominated for
something that dude is talented prisoner
so prisoners is a child abduction movie
involving two families on the cop
looking for the kids so two families are
Hugh Jackman Maria Bello and Terrence
Howard and Viola Davis
it's Thanksgiving they're all having a
good time they're hanging out it has a
really good set up and then also in the
kitchen like hey we're going to go
outside and then they're missing the
good thing about this movies it doesn't
show it happened it's just they're gone
and after that Jake Gyllenhaal is
detective Loki Loki and I that Loki
another Loki although Loki's a master of
illusion he could look like anybody but
Gyllenhaal's looking for the kids and
now we have our movie that's like two
and a half hours long this movie's
emotionally heavy I mean Gyllenhaal is
looking for these kids and Hugh
Jackman's getting frustrated so he's
yelling at Gyllenhaal as I find my
daughter and Gyllenhaal is like I am and
just you really you see both of their
sides of it I would say Hugh Jackman's a
dick in this movie but in order for me
to qualify that I will have to have been
someone whose daughter was stolen and
I'm just not I don't know what that's
like I wasn't lying about this dude
possibly get nominated for an Oscar for
this movie I'm serious this dude kills
it you know usually in a movie where
someone's really giving a good
performance you'll be able to be like oh
that's probably gonna be their oscar
clip still using the Oscars this movie
have like five of them for Jackman I was
like okay at this point let's just say
he should probably be nominated for
something really everyone was really
good in the roles I love Gyllenhaal as
the detective in this movie he's his
young detective he's really good at his
job but he has to deal with [ __ ]
it's a really realistic kind of movie I
guess I can say that this movies like if
ransom and Gone Baby Gone had a kid by a
director who's a mix of Clint Eastwood
meets David Fincher that is prisoners
the movie being two and a half hours
long and a really emotional movie you
have to be able to be like I want to see
a movie where I'm gonna watch a family
get their kid ripped away from them and
just be in the dark it's just a bad time
for this family I want to watch that for
two and a half hours I think the reality
hits you that families go through this
[ __ ] it's just like the worst tragedy
ever and this movie accurately portrays
the realism of that kind of situation
it's kind of tough to watch sometimes
you know what I'm talking about it's not
really casual watching which really
isn't an A
for the movie I'm just saying just I'm
just giving you facts here one of the
negatives is that the movie is a bit
predictable for a movie that's so well
written and so well executed it's just
it's a predictable movie there are
moments where you're like that looks
trivial and just out of the blue
something tells me it's not going to be
so I'm gonna remember that and when you
see something else that might tie into
it you remember it and you start piecing
things together and you're like I should
be a detective move over Gyllenhaal move
over Loki it's me now to the point where
I was like the last thing that happens
in this movie is going to be this and
the last shot of the movie is going to
be this and it was both those things
that depresses me when I can pick a part
of movie like that and be able to be
like oh that that and then marry there
you go it's a good crime mystery really
good acting in the movie good directing
good writing it was a bit predictable
and it's a bit emotionally heavy for two
and a half hours I take replay value
into account you want to see the movie a
second time after you get out of the
movie so you can be like okay I want to
notice things knowing exactly from the
beginning how the movies gonna play out
instead of figuring it out halfway
through the movie how the movies going
to play out in the end I will say
prisoner's is worth buying on blu-ray
for those moments where you're going
through a breakup and you're stuffing
your face with ice cream and you're like
I need to see people more miserable than
me prisoners I see your favorite crime
mystery I would say kidnapping movie but
hey we don't go that dark on my show a
favorite crime mystery if you can weave
in kidnapping movie do that whatever it
is comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you